okay
what else so we had some news that
happened man oh dude patty pimblett
patty pimblett let's start there a
little bit of news for you
if you're not familiar with this dude
he's british brother i mean and he's a
hunter he looks like um
[Music]
he looks like
all the beatles if they didn't if they
just went to the gym
you know he looks like matthew mark um
who's other guy john
and
which other guy
the little guy ringlet
he looks like all the beatles if you uh
yeah yeah matthew mark john and ringlet
he looks like all the beatles if they
just went to the gym and did no music or
drugs
and then uh
so the fight was crazy man he's real
frenetic
you know he's got that he's got a lot of
static energy you ever take something
out the dryer and it makes all that
crackling sound when you stretch it when
you pull it apart
take the sock off the sweater and it's
like
or you ever slide your feet across the
carpet at the library and then just go
shock a [ __ ]
[Music]
paddy's got that bro
patty's got that dude um
the best was though
after the fight he starts just rattling
off all kinds of quotes all all the
quotes man i can strike i can grapple um
um uh i'm the new king the new king is
here lad i can wrestle i can uh
i can do the electric slide man um the
redcoats are coming give me arasanya or
give me death uh
float like a butterfly sting like a big
girl from newcastle um he just start
going into any quote that had ever been
it was like the so much hype it was too
much you know
and then he just started just rattling
off random positive quotes he's like
give a man a fish and chips and he'll
fish and chips for a day but teach a man
to fish and chips and i'll beat the [ __ ]
out of every last one of you
like it just started to get uh
it started to just get insane and then
he just went into like just beatles
quotes you know he's like oh
black bird singing in the dead of night
take this broken bastard i just beat and
teach him to fight you pieces of [ __ ]
i'm a legend i'm a king i'm john wick
i mean he's just rattling off just
just ah
uh just just um i get by with a little
help from my fists and i'll beat the
living lips off of your mind
you're gonna know who i am
nothing's gonna change my world
[Music]
nothing's gonna change my world except
all these cash and prizes [ __ ] i'll
hard scoff your mother son
he did every hype thing you could do at
once
[Music]
but suddenly boom
i'm talking about him other people are
talking about him
you know
he'll be brendan shaw's favorite fighter
um
you know it just
it gets how it gets man you know it's
like
that's that's a unique thing about today
you can create your own hype
and patty pimlet dude he did he just he
literally just said everything that was
like ever hypeful ever you know so i'm
here for it man i'm here for paddy
pimlet i'm here to see how it goes down
and he's also in i believe
you know i don't know that much about
ufc and about fighting but um
but i love it it's become my favorite
sport over the pandemic
and um
and he's in the 155
weight class
could it get any crazier in there
could it get any crazier
so just the people he could be fighting
down the line i mean
oh it's so hype
it's so hype man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one